if you want to hear how the real-life
form of alec has a cameo in the deleted
scenes of the nun then stick around to
the end of this video welcome back to
things you missed and welcome to the end
of the year as we know it one of the
most hyped events of the year for horror
was the release of the fifth controverse
film the nun there were controversies
there were theories there was
speculation and then the movie came out
and no one really liked it but they
didn't see the deleted scenes until very
recently when they were released and I
have him and there are a couple more
connections to the conjuring franchise
and other things you missed in the
deleted scenes so let's do the part
where I tell them to you okay the first
deleted scene shows father Burke before
he gets called to the Vatican and he's
in Philadelphia sitting in the
confession booth listening to this young
boy named Timothy make his confessions
as a side note I have to wonder if the
reason the scene got cut had anything to
do with that huge scandal with the
priests in Philadelphia that happened
this year probably right around the time
that this movie was being finished you
know the thing I should never talk about
in detail if I ever want to be
considered for YouTube rewind anyway in
the scene father Burke is doing his
crossword puzzles as he's seen doing
throughout the nun however this is a
different puzzle from the one he carries
in Romania during the rest of the film
the word that comes to him is Crowe
foreshadowing one of the first things he
sees at the Abbey a flock of crows
remember when they're in the carriage
later on the way to the abbey sister
Irene helps him come up with the word
deliveries which foreshadows them going
to the delivery room I have to wonder if
coming up with the word crow could be a
hint that father Burke has a little
sliver of psychic abilities as well one
of the other words that he has written
is Bobby Thompson former cub just saying
there's also an extension of the scene
where father Burke first meets sister
Irene he tells her to pack a civilian
clothes because this will be the one
occasion in which they don't want to
broadcast their faith again it makes me
wonder if father Burke senses there's
something evil there already and he
wants to stay a bit
incognito during their approach
after father Burke and sister Irene
discover the books there's a deleted
scene of the father first taking a look
at them where we can also see some kind
of mask it kind of reminds me of the
Sonny Family Colts mask from Crips Evy
sister Irene asked why they don't just
destroy the books and this is the
father's response there's a belief in
certain circles that destroying any
object the magic completely is whatever
power was believed based on his eye this
is a reference to ed Warren's belief
that he explains in the conjuring as the
reason that they lock up all of their
cursed objects in a room why not just
throw them in an incinerator destroy and
I would only destroy the vessel
sometimes it's better to keep the genie
in the bottle I would speculate these
books from the abbey could eventually
make their way into the Warrens room of
cursed objects the father also further
explains something that I brought up in
the previous episodes on the nine which
was this symbol of the snake eating its
tail I had mentioned that the snake is a
reference to VALIC who's known as the
marquee of snakes and the father adds
that the snake consuming itself
represents the cycle of death and
rebirth now remember there were also
sightings of the symbol but with the
snakes in a figure eight like an
infinity symbol this might be a hint
that VALIC will keep being reborn
continuously that's becoming a recurring
villain in the series also in the
previous episode I pointed out the big
hit in detail that connects Lorraine
more into sister Irene's past click here
if you want to see it one of the other
pieces of evidence that contributes to
their connection was the fact that the
Vatican sent sister Irene's Romania
because of her familiarity with the
territory but she's never been to
Romania
so I speculated that the reason for
sending her was because of her visions
and her family connection to Lorraine
Warren that's basically all confirmed in
this deleted scene because you were
familiar with territory
can you mean Romanian humanity envisions
sister you are familiar with strange
phenomena the next one doesn't really
have anything as you missed so let's
move on to my favorite of the deleted
scenes because it's the creepiest this
is after Irene wakes up in the Abbey and
she's looking around last time and one
of the things I pointed out was VALIC
stability to create wind even in an
enclosed hallway here we can see that
it's definitely more than a coincidence
roll it
let me know in the comments if you
notice any unexplained indoor wind in
any of the other films there could be
references to VALIC that we haven't
uncovered yet if you've been following
my things you missed coverage of the
none you'll know that VALIC is based off
a demon known as the president of Hell
as told in the real-life book the Lesser
Key of Solomon in that book
Valek is described as an angelic Li
winged boy riding a two-headed dragon
attributed with the power of finding
treasures the non form of alec is
actually something that's unique to the
conjuring movies and when I saw these
demon like forms in the text found by
father Burke I speculated that VALIC has
the ability to change among many forms
the scene where all the nuns are praying
is extended to confirm my suspicions it
takes many forms someone in the comments
also pointed out that the demon form of
Vallot can be seen briefly at the end of
the conjuring - and I mentioned in the
previous nun episode that the child form
is not seen but referenced briefly with
this statue that suddenly has wings
the nuns also go on to explain to sister
Irene that the Abbess lost her life and
soul going up against the Baloch when I
first saw the nun I had assumed that
most of the nun spirits she encounters
at the Abbey manifestations of Alec but
with the addition of this scene I'd say
that most of them are there to help her
and the Abbess is possibly the only one
she encounters that's being controlled
by Valek our last deleted scene has
sister Irene questioning what will
happen if the evil Rhea merges and
father Burke assures her that someone
good will be there to send it back if
that does happen which foreshadows the
actions that Lorraine Warren would later
take in the conjuring - the holidays may
be over but you're still gonna want to
start off 2019 in the style and here's
how you do it you go to the Seas world
merch store and use code death mists for
10% off any of these stylish designs for
the rest of the month more importantly
we're gonna be getting a new chapter in
the conjuring universe this summer so if
you want to hear all the things you
missed in Annabelle 3 remember to
subscribe to seize these world for new
Horrors every week bring that death
bound
form notifications and I'll see you in
the next year assuming we both survive
[Music]